[MUSIC PLAYING]
MITCHELL HAMMER: I define me.
MONICA MAGALHAES: I define me.
ABIGAIL JEAN-BAPTISTE:
I define me.
MADELEINE ST JOHN:
LIZ ERICKSON: My
name is Liz Erickson.
I'm the director for
disability services
here at Princeton University.
We're actually standing right
now in the new accessibility
center.
Last night we had the
grand opening celebration.
[BACKGROUND CROWD TALKING]
So we wanted to create
a space where students
can come and be comfortable --
all students, not just
students with disabilities.
We intentionally
designed the space
for physical and
technical access,
but we want it to be
also a place where
we can foster conversation,
to educate our community,
where we can help
students with disabilities
to have a voice on campus, and
to provide some programming.
MONICA MAGALHAES:
The thing that's
different about this space
is that the space really
celebrates difference,
and by that, there's
different things
in this space that
are situated to how you
like to learn and study.
So we have a standing
table if that's
your preferred way of writing.
We have stress balls.
We have coloring books
for, like, when you just
need to de-stress.
And I also think
it's really important
that there's a lot
of vivid colors
that really keep
you excited to be
in the space and, like,
awake and productive.
MICHELE MINTER:
I'm Michele Minter.
I'm the vice provost
for institutional equity
and diversity and the
University's ADA coordinator.
And I think this center is
a big moment for Princeton.
This is our moment for
really celebrating,
not just what disabilities
bring to our community,
but what all of the
differences in ability
bring to our community.
MITCHELL HAMMER: The space
has been a long time coming
and it feels good,
I think, for people
in the community, outside
of the community, just
to have that official seal
of approval from Princeton
by having this space
available to them.
Like so many other
affinity groups on campus
have space that they
can connect with
and, that's made for them,
and for their friends.
LIZ ERICKSON: Students can
come in and have access
without the space
shouting out, you
need an accommodation
for something.
ABIGAIL JEAN-BAPTISTE:
We're hoping
to lift some of the stigma
centered around disabilities
with this space where people
can have conversations and just
be in the same room
together as opposed
to feeling like they're alone.
MADELEINE ST JOHN:
I think it's great.
I think it's really
opened up the space.
The colors and the
paintings, and it's really
created a warmer, nicer-sized
space and a space,
I think, students would
really like to come to.
LIZ ERICKSON: And we
really want students
to know that we are now open.
We want to encourage students
to come and enjoy this space.
[MUSIC PLAYING]